President Biden has signed a bill to
block a threatened National Railroad
Strike the walkout could have crippled
the supply chain and cost the U.S
economy about two billion dollars a day
the Biden Administration is pointing to
the legislation and to new numbers as
proof that the economy is on track the
November jobs report showed the economy
added an unexpected 263 thousand jobs
unemployment held at 3.7 percent Skyler
Henry is at the White House with the
very latest Skyler good morning hey Dana
good morning to you will President Biden
says the country's in a position now
where things are quote moving in the
right direction especially in the midst
of the holiday season but he admits the
measure he signed Friday averting a
costly Nationwide rail strike didn't
meet all the demands of its union
workers
but we still have more work to do
President Biden leaned Into the Now law
he signed preventing a looming National
Rail strike the bill I'm about to sign
ends a difficult rail dispute and helps
our nation avoid what without a doubt
would have been an economic catastrophe
at a very bad time in the calendar
the measure imposes a labor agreement
for rail workers following a brokered
September agreement and will avert a
nationwide rail disruption in the midst
of the holiday season
the bill signing comes alongside a
better than expected jobs report from a
worker's standpoint we should be feeling
good about wage growth and the fact that
the unemployment rates close to its
lowest point in 50 years on Friday the
labor department reported the U.S
economy added more than 260 thousand
jobs Divine interest rate hikes and high
inflation though there were areas to
improve Americans are working the
economy is growing wages are rising
faster than inflation President Biden
spent Friday touting the good news ahead
of a trip to Boston for meeting with
Prince William
the Royals made the trip to highlight
their fight against climate change and
prioritizing Mental Health
officials say the two men met for about
30 minutes William thanking Mr Biden for
attending the Queen's funeral in
September
President Biden is also facing another
looming deadline Congress is running out
of time to pass a government funding
bill which is set to expire in two weeks
the president is also looking to shore
up more funding for Ukraine and its war
against Russia and billions more to help
fight against covid and other diseases
by the end of the year Dana back to you
all right Skyler thank you